buongiorno a tutti
oddio sono un po emozionata comunque
oggi io sono qua perché vi voglio
parlare delle mie origini
le mie origini sono state lente io mi
ricordo che a cinque anni fissavo il
foglio mi perdevo e poi tornavo normale
scrivevo mi perdevo e poi tornava
normale e questo mi capitava più e più
volte al giorno
spesso mi sentivo dire stai attenta mi
segui
ed effettivamente avevano ragione
io per prima pensava di essere distratta
solo che continuava
la mia fortuna però è stato trovare
delle maestre che avevano capito che
c'era qualcosa che non andava
e a questo punto le mie origini hanno
preso una piega diversa
io soffrivo di epilessia con assenza
tutti bene o male conosciamo l'epilessia
nella sue forme più classiche ovvero con
le convulsioni e con le scosse tonico
clonney che
però riconoscere l'epilessia nelle sue
forme meno eclatanti come l'epilessia
con l'assenza o piccolo male è un
pochino più difficile in questo caso le
crisi sono caratterizzate da sospensioni
della coscienza colpisce il bambino era
molto piccola intorno ai 5 anni
e rimane come bambola toe con lo sguardo
perso nel vuoto se durante queste crisi
lui viene chiamato non risponde
e se gli viene chiesto a cosa stesse
pensando
lui non se lo ricorda lo sviluppo
neurologico in un bambino con epilessia
cole assenza è assolutamente normale
sono solamente questi brevi attimi di
assenza che possono far scattare un
campanello d'allarme nei genitori degli
insegnanti
ora vi voglio far vedere una foto
questo quello che vedete qua l attrice
fotogramma è un elettroencefalogramma
queste onde qua questo è un pochino più
grandi erano movimenti in cui il mio
cervello si spegneva
pensate quanto può essere difficile per
un bambino con epilessia con assenza
seguire la lezione un'età così piccola
starò attento ed imparare
immaginatevi un bambino che fa un
dettato e la maestra detta e lui scrive
ogni tanto magari saltava lettera poi
una parola e magari alla fine cifra
neanche un brutto voto spesso questo
disturbo non vi ha identificato e quindi
il bambino viene etichettato come uno
con la testa tra le nuvole un po
svogliata e disattento
perché ho deciso di raccontarvi questa
storia perché io sono stata fortunata e
stato identificato il problema e sono
guarita ma per molti bambini non è così
molti vivono la loro vita al di sotto
delle loro potenzialità
precludendosi opportunità di studio e di
lavoro solo perché nessuno si è accorto
quale fosse il problema
a volte mi chiedo che cosa sarebbe stato
di me se non mi fossi fatta curare chi
lo sa magari non avrei avrei fatto le
superiori si sicuramente con un po di
difficoltà magari non avrei fatto
l'università oppure non mi sarei
laureata o magari non avrei fatto l'anno
all'estero in costa rica
questa è una foto di me e dei miei
compagni di classe l'ultimo giorno di
scuola
e stata un'esperienza bellissima
pensate a quanto mi sarei persa perché
convinta di non poterlo fare di non
essere all'altezza o che non facesse per
me
ora vi faccio vedere un'altra foto
questa questa è la mia famiglia e queste
sono i genitori
per un genitore ammettere che il proprio
figlio era sta un pochino più lento
rispetto agli altri è difficile e
ovviamente colpendo il bambino un'età
così piccola coinvolge anche tutta la
famiglia e nel mio caso aver avuto due
genitori attenti molto pazienti e attivi
ha fatto sì che io risolversi prima vi
dicevo quanto può essere difficile per
un bambino con epilessia con assenza
starà attenta in classe di imparare
elementari per me non sono state un
periodo semplice ero sempre un pochino
indietro nell'apprendimento però sempre
un pochino più lenta rispetto agli altri
ma i genitori hanno fatto in modo che io
non sentissi ma il difetto
ecco io nella mia vita non mi sono mai
sentita da meno
poi se proprio devo dirla tutta
cioè non è che ibra sia passato tanto
male perché ogni volta mi portavano a
fare un esame o faranno accertamento in
ospedale dove facevamo tappa al
mcdonald's o a fare colazione al bar
quindi se proprio devo dire la verità io
non mi sono accorta mai di nulla e me la
sono vista proprio bene
però molti genitori non sanno da dove
partire
quindi io vi dico che la diagnosi è
molto semplice
consiste in un elettroencefalogramma un
esame assolutamente non invasivo e la
cura è altrettanto semplice
basta assumere dei farmaci per un
periodo e nella maggior parte dei casi
come è successo a me si guarisce
ora però mi voglio rivolgere a te che
come me sei nato con un'origine un
pochino più lenta rispetto agli altri la
vita a volte ti mette davanti a delle
spazi e difficili ma bisogna reagire
bisogna circondarsi delle persone
persone giuste farsi coraggio ea piccoli
passi piano piano dal lento si può
diventare veloce e in alcuni casi anche
un po più veloce rispetto agli altri
bisogna trasformare una debolezza in un
punto di forza
soprattutto
ricordati che non sei solo non lo sono
stata io ma di certo non lo sarai anche
tu
grazie
grazie mille